hey guys it is the 26th of me today and
my name is just McDonald you're watching
games but news which today comes with an
extra side of fries just for you let's
talk about some video games first up the
future is coming to video games yet
again and you'll be able to try it out
for yourself in none other than call of
duty advanced warfare sad future comes
in the form of fancy weapons and gear
including a 3d printer gun plasma rifles
hoverbikes and EXO suits game informer
dug into the nitty-gritty of the new
weapons for the game which is set in
2050 for the 3d printer gun can
apparently print ammunition on the fly
within the weapons chamber presumably a
hell of a lot faster than it currently
takes to 3d print anything because
otherwise you'd probably die let me know
what your fantasy weapon of the future
would be for a video game in the
comments we haven't received any
official word on another fallout game
but project director of new vegas josh
soja hopes that it'll hurt real good so
i told Eurogamer fallout games are best
when the choices are and this applies to
role-playing games in general but
fallout is a more desperate world more
agonizing they feel more appropriate to
the post apocalyptic genre so I hope
that whatever twists and turns the story
takes its more nuanced to than a black
and white choice he said that the
original 2d Fallout games and new Vegas
were designed to challenge the player
and that he thinks there's a segment of
players who want their apocalyptic
wasteland to be as threatening and
morally grey as you'd expect an
apocalyptic wasteland to be last off the
mark today the PlayStation is making its
way to China Sony's partnered up with
shanghai oriental pearl group co limited
yet another excellent company named
presumably derived from picking random
woods out of a hat to take advantage of
the fact of the country no longer bans
the sale of consoles as it has for 14
years to date Business Week has reported
that the partnership are forming two
ventures to make himself PlayStation
consoles in the region though there's
currently no time frame for when the
systems will hit the market last month
microsoft said they'd be releasing the
xbox one in china this sep tember to the
market is a pretty important one to grab
since the statistics from the games
marketing summit indicate
the number of gamers in china surpassed
the total population of the u.s. i'll
give you a second to get your head
around that one let me know whether you
reckon Sony or Microsoft will have
better luck with their system sales in
china in that commenting section down
below or if you prefer to abstain from
the whole console war you can definitely
do that that is it for me today but
tomorrow I'll have even more things to
say to your face so join me again then